[Music]
in catfight news motion picture for this
one you don't know what he meant
submitted by Bart's wrists let's see him
beef between Nicki Minaj and cardi B are
you serious he doesn't care about your
have you heard about what they've been
saying each others but no I know but I
feel it I feel like every time I'm here
I thought we just do a day of cardi B
versus Nicki it's so funny I want it to
lead it to like a boxing match I love
parties
I like cardio I like Nicki Minaj too
good I think she's hot as hell it's not
okay a bo-beat between Nicki Minaj and
cardi B is now involving Steve Mann and
50 Cent's - there's this supposedly some
fake deal that was going around and then
someone's calling Steve Madden like a
liar suddenly there was tell you all
about
wait let me can I guess cuz didn't uh
didn't Nicki Minaj like throw a shoe
accorded me or some [ __ ] yeah and maybe
Steve man's like hey if you're gonna do
that again better have my name on the
same boat oh yeah yeah I we don't want
so the reason you even have to watch
that American sport because if I thought
it was a shewbread oh yeah if you watch
you guys see the social network yeah cuz
like where did they do put you in a
place I [ __ ] put myself in my place
boy what about it though he's in the
wolf of Wall Street Steve Madden he's
portrayed he was trying to put us in our
place cuz he we all tried
no so he was um he was I see owing or
not I ceiling yeah he was yeah he was
going public with this shoe company and
then Jordan Belfort was the one taking
them public alright so the drama here
with cardi B and Nicki Minaj apparently
started about more than a year ago and
the most recent thing unless you guys
want me to go through the entire drama
I'm gonna skip all that I'm assuming you
guys know all that right now the most
recent thing is that Nicki Minaj on her
podcast she started talking about that
fight that happened yeah she has a
podcast oh she doesn't Jesus yes maybe
Ryan only podcast you don't have bakas
you're the one guy on yeah I don't
either
well technically David's videos are
podcasting G that's true good morning
guys
[ __ ] you in her podcast Nicki Minaj was
saying that in reality it wasn't the
security guard that hits cardi be like
how she initially said that it was her
friend Raleigh which is Nicki's friend
as she was the one that really gave her
them is Raleigh a first name or a first
name and last name
two separate names or first amendment a
raw I'm raw Lee are a H Rob Lee Barney
Marley yeah she's from a lovin hip hop
like that show so I don't know what that
is either
it's a reality show okay yeah so then
she was claiming that and then that
Nicki Minaj is like anybody that I want
to pull up with surveillance footage
I'll give you $100,000 she didn't say
footages footage where who said that a
cardi B or Nicki no Nicki's I thought
she would say footage just say
here footages all right now I love the
idea welcome to the Nicki Minaj podcast
she's like super calm down the whole
things that yeah so like free yeah
exactly
her she's like I'm so grateful for my
low bed she's like we'll be right back
after a quick word from audible.com a
lot of times so anyway so then as she
was saying that and then that's when she
was also making other claims about cardi
that cardi told other artists not to
work with Nikki and I feel like cardio
doesn't even have that type of clout
like I feel like the one that has more
clout right now is Nikki because she's
just been in the game longer but
whatever yeah so then that prompted
cardi to do eleven Instagram videos oh
my god you didn't see it they were good
she was so Street with the whole thing
when is she not yeah that's a good point
get real though yes then she ended up
saying that so cardi peas sister
Hennessy that's [ __ ] tight she claims
Bacardi and Hennessy me be
Raleigh well those aren't their real
name well what's a real name I don't
know just know that that's not there
anyway so there's this funny we all
chose names like that how much you want
to bet that's a real name though Bacardi
and uh Hennessy it's not weird Dominican
or some [ __ ] I don't know but it's not
it's crazy enough okay it's not a common
name okay it's like Lamoni or something
this is like me with my family trying to
tell them anything about current events
or [ __ ] celebrity culture and they're
all just like what's the damn thing
what's the guy
so anyway so Hennessey was claiming that
Nikki's people leaked cardi B's phone
number and then that's when in cardi B
like whole videos she ended up pulling
out her phone and was like showing these
hateful text messages that all came from
Nikki's fans and then she was saying
like Oh who's the common denominator
here because other people's phone
numbers have been leaked that you guys
had you couldn't leak Hennessey's phone
number because you don't have it all
this stuff right and then that's when
Nikki was responding on Twitter and I
wonder her responses she said this Oh
because then cardi was like I'm not the
one that's stopping your bags like you
know getting money from working with
other people it was actually you that it
you've been doing that to me and like
they're both claiming that to each other
right both claiming that they're telling
people not to work with us yeah so then
Nikki says same thing with Steve Madden
Irv Gotti asked me to do that deal
several times I passed you never hear me
talking about things like this she
really thought she was doing something
talking about turning down deals ahahaha
I know she's promoting it can you redo
that laughter me more time please you
please thank you hahaha more gut into it
yeah the van she ends up saying baby
girl write a rap because Nikki Minaj is
also claiming that cardi B doesn't write
her up and then that's when Steve Madden
responds and says and it's magical you
just turn a laptop around in those tweet
just change makes you press a button
yeah don't don't tell them the magic
he's easily entertained your [ __ ]
zooming in on [ __ ] laugh at your [ __ ]
dick off you can't turn down an offer
that was never made hashtag stoplight
Wow Wow he's backing up Kearney or the
truth at least so that 50 cent and like
20 or like posting this on his Instagram
and says this guy is a liar you liar you
lol and then Pinocchio notes and then
like he has this and then he posted
another thing that says I guess he
forgot he spoke on this already shaking
my head liar and what is written here it
says another actress raps trous who
could have collected a check from Madden
and ironically eggy's faux Nicki Minaj
oh [ __ ] I was gonna do a collaboration
with Nicki Minaj and we got into a fight
the first minute we met he recalls
without pinpointing the exact cause and
then we patched it up we were cool we
text each other we became sort of
buddies we were thinking of doing
something and I went up but I was with
Iggy and I thought Coke and Pepsi it was
a mistake I made a mistake and I wish I
could go back in time and work with
Nicki instead of Iggy so that's what
Steve Madden said and then oh wait you
did lie cuz he was trying to work out a
deal with Nicki yeah did he why did he
do that I think he's already just forgot
himself he didn't even have to step in
though I know but I think that because
he's old he thought he was like you know
what I got some beef well that Steve
Maddens are like less relevant now so
maybe he's trying to get himself a boost
I don't wanna buy anything he ended up
saying or anything it's all black people
look the same he tweeted this out which
says Nicki Minaj is an incredibly
talented artist where we couldn't work
together cuz the timing wasn't right
cardi B came on the scene and I had a
fantastic collaboration with her and she
is also an amazing talent I love both
Nicki Minaj and cardi B's music I hope
they can reach some piece together they
could probably take over the world there
is a lot of negativity out there right
now and I shouldn't have contributed to
that Steve potato check out what Nicki
Minaj says
[Laughter]
thank you light on because there's my
favorite there's a trendy thing to do
ain't nobody buying that clown [ __ ] we
couldn't work together cuz I said the
shoes were ugly you see how when you do
clownery it comes back to bite we're not
buying it response to Fibby instead of
picking on women cuz you won't respond
to 50 cent just with these that posted
on well concerns not relevant
I wouldn't respond to me they love it in
the middle of all of this Maury pops up
get the [ __ ] out of my face I'll pay you
to take a lie-detector test about every
claim she was telling cardi B and then
Laurie's like white paper a lie detector
test when mine is free I'll get to the
bottom of it
yes find out what your parents are and
then Mickey respond Maury I'm ready
that's job they'll promoting the dip
video like every single Queen can love
more eat love more and show us soulful
it would be like on some ridiculous [ __ ]
where it's like it would be like two
white people right and there's a black
baby like I got to find out this child's
mind around and I say supposedly I'm
their father because he's like he's like
stewing the whole time and then when he
finally gets a chance to talk he's like
he's like I just don't believe that that
child is mine
and then it's always the same exact
thing right where they like it turns out
sir there's a pause the baby is not
yours but it's like that's a black baby
of course it's not your baby how do you
build that in the drama
even you're the funniest part too is
when they find out they're not the
father and they celebrate the [ __ ] out
of the girl space
or the girl just sits there like chillin
I love all that [ __ ] they had to do that
[ __ ] yeah I love no Davis some hide a
sore leg lyin ass [ __ ]
I have the anterior tibialis me a break
everybody we do we do a lot to our
bodies for biz I do I'm sorry I can't
kick [ __ ] with it though you [ __ ]
monster Yeah right exactly
alright to bring this on to a conclusion
Nicki Minaj tweeted this out okay you
guys let's focus on positive things only
from Harris she just said eat a dick did
she song she very David so thank you
yeah she's like we're also blessed I
know this stuff is entertaining and
funny to a lot of people but I won't be
discussing this nonsense anymore thank
you for the support and encouragement
year after year love you and so pretty
beat took a screenshot of that tweet
posted up herself and she was like all
right then let's focus on positive dude
positivity you can't do anything
so do they squash it or is I don't want
to see a fight that's gonna be the
sorriest fight on earth yeah it wouldn't
be fun I'm not trying to why that
[ __ ] what's it called what's his name
Logan Paul in this [ __ ] case I [ __ ]
was black too
well that was a little more like two
guys they were way on on each other for
sure but when two girls fight it's sort
of like a Looney Tunes thing where
there's like a tornado and I can't
really see what's going on especially
like two untrained fighters you just
gotta tie in a ponytail and then you
just see everything okay well no but
they also wear flowy outfits and [ __ ]
too I just feel like everything gets
lost you gotta wear fight wear yeah
that's true they gotta wear fighting
your world in a rig with just the
regular clothes
[Laughter]
yeah yeah I wasn't thinking like a UFC
fight like we run around here we're
having a [ __ ] yeah exactly that streep
raw that's the only way that's the only
thing I've seen you know every time that
they fight it's always in some shitty
granular video and it's half lit and
then there's I can't see what's
happening they need better lighting for
this video
[Music]